you
hi my name is Astrid first of all I want
to say how thrilled I am to be here and
thank you to the organizers for such an
amazing conference with such a great
number of speakers I've learned so much
too some last day and a half so my name
is Astrid and I'm meant to be starting a
PhD tomorrow but I'm at Jas comps so I
pushed it a week I'm actually starting
next week at Queen Mary in London my
area of specialization is media
technology and that's my website Astra
been calm you can see the stuff I do and
on Twitter I'm disaster it and what I'm
gonna be talking about is how JavaScript
can influence how we tell stories
because I really feel that storytelling
is changing for the first time in about
well it's evolved over the last hundred
years but it's starting to go will
undergo a real change and JavaScript's
one of the technologies that can really
help with this or inform this this
change so that's what I'm gonna be
talking to you about today the first
things first I'm not a developer I know
most people who talk here are developers
I'm not one of you but what I am is I'm
an artist a designer a researcher and a
writer and when I say research show me
at such an ambiguous term but really
what I mean by that is noticing trends
and culture and noticing trends and
creative output and in culture in
general and identifying where more work
can be done that's really what what I do
everything I'm talking about today I'm
going to talk about two of my projects
and one project by somebody else that
I've never met but when I talk about my
projects
I'm not these projects aren't just by me
I actually work with a partner this is
Pete he is a developer some of you might
know him he's a front-end developer and
digital artist beat hockey he's my bike
we do a lot of creative work together
and you know we're also married but you
can find him at peat hockey comment on
Twitter as Pete of Republic and
we kind of work together in these sorts
of digital projects so that's what I'm
kind of gonna talk about today the first
when we talk about storytelling we've
really got to talk about what where do
we get these ideas and what a story is
and how a story works because my story's
been around since the beginning of time
but we all understand stories in like
very specific ways and one of the
biggest influencers on that is of course
Hollywood and I know we all want to
thank well you know like Hollywood's not
you know the be-all and end-all of
stories but it has been the most
influential thing in the Western world
on storytelling in the last hundred
years and its advances in its own
technology and it's a its creative
manipulation of that technology has been
really really influential so I'm gonna
talk about how the Hollywood model of
storytelling is starting to break down
and where technologies like JavaScript
can kind of get in there and push
forward and change how we use how we
approach stories the Hollywood story
this I mean a million PhD theses can be
written on this topic of how Hollywood
tells stories so I'm gonna talk about
three really specific tiny little points
but this isn't by no means exhaustive
first thing is that it with the
Hollywood model stories are meant to be
consumed in a specific venue and as also
that stories are consumed passively by
the audience that you see even when you
rent a movie or you download a movie and
you sit at home and watch it you're
sitting in front of a screen and it
shows a bit of posture associated with
it a physicality associated with it and
the third thing is that stories are
dependent on chronology and their
designs deliver an emotional response
and there's very specific reasons for
all these things and but right now what
we expect from stories and more
importantly what counts as a story is
changing and when you have these three
elements of Hollywood storytelling
there's very they kind of break down to
three really simple ideas which is where
we experience stories how we experience
them and what purpose stories serve so
that's really the three elements that
I'm talking about and where they come
from the first question is where where
do we consume stories in the Hollywood
model and traditionally at
movie theater and there's always reasons
for these things and the reason for that
was because that's where the projector
lives and the whole idea I mean when I'm
you know looking at the the tradition of
Hollywood I was like but that's crazy
that your technology lived in one
specific place in the center of town you
had to pay to go and look at it like
amazing because now the technology is
everywhere and this is one way that I
won really influential way that I think
stories are starting to change the story
that the project I'm going to talk about
now is one that's very close to my own
heart it was a called the redemption
machines and redemption machines was a
pervasive media story that was told via
smartphone it was it was built in
PhoneGap using javascript and what the
redemption machines was was a story
about man versus machine but it took
place in Belfast has anyone here ever
been to Northern Ireland is anyone ever
been to Belfast couple people now what
everybody knows about Belfast is that
you know it's the trouble listen there's
been a civil war there for you know
decades but what people tend to forget
even people that live there is that 200
years ago Belfast was the most it was
the wealthiest part of Britain and it
was actually the center of British
technology and engineering and that was
because of the industrial tradition in
Belfast and now you look at you look at
the city and people that live there
don't even notice this architecture
these incredible buildings that are left
over from this glittering industrial
past that everyone's forgotten about so
I developed this project called the
redemption machines and it was a story
that led the viewer around the city so
it used the story as a stage and it used
the buildings as players and it was an
audio story that was delivered by
headphones and it was administered by a
smartphone so that is this is and if
there was no mobile phones this wouldn't
have been possible now I'm going to I've
made a short video for something else
I'm actually going to show you now and
maybe I'll show you now here we go
remember when I had a cursor there it is
mission machines is a pervasive media
experience means that stands at the
intersection of fiction audio art
theater and game and allows the
participant to interact with their urban
surroundings in a new and meaningful way
it premiered in Belfast Northern Ireland
in May 2013 using Belfast existing
social and architectural history woven
into a fictional narrative the
redemption machines breathe life into
the urban terrain by activating Belfast
past glory days of industrialization
when mechanization changes city's
fortunes forever the story also
investigates the human-machine
relationship reflecting on what the
costs and benefits are of mass
production and mechanization on a grand
scale here's how it works the starting
point for the experience was a gallery
participants arrived at the gallery and
it was set up to look like a waiting
room and I was performing the role of
attendant they were issued with
headphones and a smartphone running a
custom-designed app they sat down and
tap the screen when they were ready
which triggered the audio story this
where you're standing is the membrane
place a place between the human and
machine worlds it's the world where the
walls are closing in a world whose
integrity is failing we need your help
there have been events that bring
machines and humans together too closely
the events going on at the moment it
happens are trapped here doomed to an
eternity of repetition the ghosts must
be released and the repetition must end
the participant departs from the gallery
and moves around the city to a variety
of stop points checking in with the app
each time to receive a story's next
chapter the first stop near the gallery
is belfast oldest public building now a
disused eyesore it has not always been
this way and was originally used as a
meeting place for those made wealthy by
the products of industrialization if you
can stare past your own reflection you
can see an empty room there are ghosts
here and there having a party the ghosts
sip deeply from their bottomless glasses
of good drink and the scent of fresh-cut
flowers lingers in the air
the sunlight comes through the window
these ghosts were once human beings
raised to the upper classes by the
machines they commandeered steam power
somewhere else does the work for them
and the humans that stoke those great
fires live a very different existence
but now just look at them twirling and
eating having the same conversation
dance begins again not far away's bridge
street an unremarkable thoroughfare that
sustained a direct bombing hit during
World War two during which Belfast
suffered the highest numbers of civilian
casualties in the UK outside of London
starting at 10:00 p.m.
wave after wave of landmines and
incendiary explosives rained down on the
city the planes kept coming Bridge
Street where you are standing was
obliterated by a direct hit this was a
high-density working-class area reduced
to dust and rubble humanity had learned
to fully wield machines as weapons of
war as instruments of mass destruction
so that was the Redemption machines it
was something that allowed the viewer to
stand in the environment of the story
world and this is not this is kind of
goes against this what one of the most
exciting things about mobile technology
I think is the ability to place viewers
within the story world instead of having
to look at a screen that's a window to a
fictional world and uncoupling the
storytelling experience from the theater
from a from a seat is I think that's
something that is really important and
that was built in PhoneGap I wrote it
recorded it produced it design the
interface and Pete implemented it in
PhoneGap using the PhoneGap API I know
everyone has diverging opinions on
PhoneGap but without PhoneGap that
wouldn't been possible just let me how
do you even so that's the redemption
machines the other thing that I'd like
to talk about is how we how we confront
stories how we consume them and
traditionally the audience sits in a in
a
you know in a theater seat and watches a
movie and passively consumes it we're
supposed to have this sort of you know
emotional experience with the roomful of
strangers and however one thing that
I've been really interested in is how
the audience how the person is
experiencing the story can influence it
and the reason traditionally is because
the story's independent of the audience
and it happens to them so started
playing with how the audience can happen
to the story and now the story can
respond to the viewer and this is one
thing that I've been really interested
in with browser games actually and there
was one thing that Pete and I again
produced for a Microsoft Game Jam called
Dark Tower we wanted to produce an
audio-only game and I realize I'm
showing you a bunch of audio stuff so
you're just listening to me like blah
blah blah this whole time so it's bear
with me but Dark Tower was a game that
has almost no interface and it's all
audio and the idea was to create a
immersive audio environment and we did
this with the library buzz jas which
allows you to turn on and off various
audio files as in response to events so
what I will do is I will show you a
little bit of Dark Tower Dark Tower is
played in the browser and the whole idea
is that this is atmospheric and as you
the ideas that you wake up in the top of
the tower and you've got to find a way
to make it down to the bottom but you
can't see anything you can only listen
and each you know it's kind of a horror
story so each room has its own like
gross things you only experience by
audio but I'll show you a little bit now
you wake up in a room it's dark your
head hurts the taste of blood is in your
mouth your lips are cracked something is
poking into your back you are crumpled
on a metal bed frame that is pushing
that springs into your body you become
aware of something on your face
something wet it's water leaking from
somewhere above you you can hear a storm
outside rain falling on the roof the sky
feels close from where you are as you
feel your vision fight for focus you are
alarmed you can see nothing you wake
your hand in front of your face nothing
a moment to panic have you gone blind
you turn your head to the side and
detect a shift between shades black on
the wall you realize you're not blind
you're just in complete darkness you
experience a moment of clarity and your
confusion gives way to a feeling that
seems primal old it's fear why are you
here how did you get here you shiver as
you realize you're wearing pajamas that
have been dripped on for some time
adrenaline floods your limbs panic grips
your heart you're overcome with a desire
to get out of here but how the fear
bubbles up inside you and you want to
yell out shout into the darkness maybe
someone will hear you and help now
there's a choice do you want to shout
help hello or is there anybody there
what do you think is there anybody there
there's no response so each time you
experience an event in dark tower you
want to move you want to get out of here
each time you get you get a choice in
dark tower the audience the audio shifts
and especially as you move down through
the tower the audio environment of each
room shifts and fades in and out and all
of that is done by amplifying and
attenuating very and fading in and
fading out various tracks as it's about
I think is that there's about 50 tiny
audio tracks involved in that whole
thing so it's this concert of audio
tracks that is all controlled by buzz
Jay yes and a great thing is that
because it's not one long audio track it
can really respond to the to the viewers
actions and button presses hang on a
second I've lost it I've lost a cursor
there it is so that was Dark Tower and
as I said like usually when you produce
audio it's it's you have all of these
different discrete tracks and you mix
them all down to one track whereas with
buzz Jay s what we did was we had all of
these different tracks going on at once
and depending on the events that happen
through the viewer you they turn on and
off they fade in and out so this was
great to create like a really
atmospheric and rich audio environment
and it's also the best part it's really
easy to edit if you have one mix down
track if you need to make a change
you've got to like go back into the da W
inline-6 a little bit and then mix it
all down again and export it whereas
this you can change just a little bit if
like the beginning part there that I was
showing you I think there were seven
audio tracks playing at that point but
you know there's a wind there's a
mechanical roar there's the rain there's
the vocal there's like all this stuff
going on and if you want to change or
adjust any of that environment you only
have to change you only have to edit one
little track put it back into the put it
back into the app and then it accepts
that change so that was what Dark Tower
and that was something that I was really
inspired by audio wise was this idea of
being able to respond to audience events
the last thing I'm going to talk about
is what purpose we what purpose there is
with stories and stories were have
always been used by Hollywood in a very
specific way and a lot of those reasons
are economical is that they want to sell
tickets so there was this idea of using
a story as an emotional experience that
you need to experience in a specific
place in a specific way and the reason
you did that is because want people to
sell tickets to buy tickets to have that
experience there's a lot of economical
reasons behind why we've been
experiencing stories in this way for the
love all through the 20th century and
even till now
and so what counted as a story was a
story with conflict that elicits an
emotional response
now if anyone's interested in movies or
you're interested in the story telling
is there 100 Joseph Campbell's everyone
know Joseph Campbell he wrote yeah he
wrote this book called the hero with a
thousand faces and if you're at all
interested in writing or stories or
screenplays or movies read this book
because what Joseph Campbell did he was
a sociologist who and a comparative
literature expert and he went and looked
at stories from like ancient myths like
Beowulf and like you know oral history
myths all the way up to Hollywood movies
in the 20th century and he picked out
what are the parts what are the things
in stories that human beings respond to
and his ideas were taken on board
completely by Hollywood and really have
influenced the way that Hollywood
structure stories there's always a hero
who has a quest and then he gets starts
the quest and someone gives him
something and then he goes on the quest
and he has this big ordeal he might meet
people along the way then he enters the
belly of the beast by himself and he
overcomes it and then he returns this
hero thing and this is true from like
you know Beowulf
to Gone with the Wind to the matrix to
Wizard of Oz this this model of stories
is very very pervasive and so but these
stories have always been used by
Hollywood to sell tickets right there
and that there's an emotional response
there that's what the audience is
getting is this emotional experience in
a very specific context and all of that
is there's very clear economic reasons
but now stories are not only used for
emotional response and not only used to
communicate these like you know
chronological events but also they can
be applied to all sorts of things and
were uncoupling stories from this light
really stories are appearing everywhere
they're not only delivered to us by you
know media giants there's stories can be
applied to all kinds of interesting
things and when you think about
chronological events what struck me when
I started thinking about like alright
well what is the story if it's a series
of chronological events then lots of
things or stories instructions or
stories methods or stories procedures or
stories and so what is it that that you
know makes those things different or how
can we bring story elements to a set of
instructions to make them more
interesting or more appealing and one of
the most beautiful examples I've seen of
this is something called Penguin Navi
this was a project that was done in
Japan and I'm just going to show you the
video because I don't even think I can
explain it this is Tokyo 35 year old
aquarium here there are so many
thousands of things to do even worse the
aquarium is almost a kilometer from the
station but that was our job we had to
attract the visitors the aquarium and
make sure they could find it idea let
banelings bring people to the aquarium
so we created GPS penguin
by using a our GPS Penguins will show
you the way to the aquarium oh you
people can't help but to follow them
what an amazing sense of road direction
we human beings are magically drawn to
cute animals human instinct need new
technology it was a world first motion
capture technology applied to penguins
are GPS penguins walk exactly like real
penguin genuine penguin movements are
you deducing the serotonin that you must
me result mobile phones change boring
point-to-point travel into entertainment
just follow the penguin you won't notice
other distractions
you'll arrive at the aquarium's before
you know it look people continue coming
today with this ah
domination company GPS payments for hot
topic in many media
emmalin's brought not only people
but also smile now I saw that at a
conference recently has anyone ever seen
something so delightful I just thought
that was such an amazing way of applying
story to what is basically a procedure
and I found that I found that really
inspiring and I that really made me
think like what what is it that you know
we're actually telling what stories are
we telling and that was made with an AR
authoring system called Mateo
M ETA IO I didn't put on the slide which
is really bad form of mine and what it
is that is a custom browser called you
neo
so I'm trying to get the presentation up
but my cursor is not cooperating and
Mateo is based in Munich actually and
they have various offices around the
world but their biggest offices in
Munich and it's an AR authoring system
that uses JavaScript to glue together
the SDK and the HTML the logic is
written in JavaScript and you also write
they you style the GPS features like
bubbles that would appear on maps and
stuff like that with jf and you also use
jf to listen for and handle events like
screen tap and stuff like that and I was
just blown away by this I mean first of
all I would follow that was penguins
into hell playa and but I thought what a
beautiful way of applying making this
into a story except it's not a story
with a beginning a middle and an end but
there is a story there that where are
these penguins going why are they going
there they're getting home like I've got
I gotta go I gotta follow them and I
thought that was such a beautiful way of
using applying a story to what is
generally just a procedure so what we
expect from stories and what counts as a
story is changing and and these are
three ways that jss is doing this with
enabling mobile I mean we can do all
these things with a number of a number
of different technologies but these
three were done with gjs which is this
application done in PhoneGap which puts
the audience member in
the center of the imaginary world mixing
mixing audio mixing various audio tracks
in order to create these atmospheric
environments and also applying story and
like whimsy and delight to a very boring
set of instructions so that's really all
I have to say but this is where that's
that's me
Astrid Ben Esther Ben calm and on
Twitter I'm disaster 'add and Pete is
Pete hawky
he's a front-end j/s developer and
digital artist he's also in London
that's his website that's him on Twitter
and that's really all I have to say
thanks very much
you